Tom Curren Patriots insider NBC sports
Boston joining us on the program Tom
what was the mood like when you went to
the Patriots camp yesterday I think it
was anticipatory of a fairly tense day
interesting when you go into the Bill
Belichick press conference you
understand how it was going to unfold
and it unfolded pretty much as expected
but in the locker room
players are guarded but understanding of
this circus is going to go on because
they've seen some circuses in the past
over the last 10 years 20 years if
you're Tom Brady and they know how to
approach it
Drew Rosenhaus Antonio Brown agent went
on ESPN yesterday and he alluded to the
fact that he and Antonio Brown knew that
there was a possibility of this lawsuit
coming you know their way did the
Patriots know about this prior to
signing Antonio Brown that's what I
really think we need to get to the
bottom of because the Patriots on Monday
and into Tuesday excuse me Tuesday into
Wednesday expressed surprise to both
Adam Schefter
and Ian Rapoport and then again Charles
Robinson in a story for Yahoo Sports
stating sources say both the league and
the Patriots were surprised by this so
that leads me to believe this stand
either true Rosenhaus was not asked and
that means the Patriots weren't doing
due diligence on a guy who really needs
to diligence done on the Patriots did
ask and rosenhouse lied or rosenhouse
was asked told the Patriots or a segment
of the Patriots an arm of the Patriots
what was going on and that message
didn't pass all the way through the
organization and now they have a
situation the Patriots do where their
brand is attached to a player who's
attached to a lawsuit the NFL is all
about their image their perception the
the right thing to do not necessarily
fairness but the right thing to do would
be to sit Antonio Brown down I'm
guessing is that the smart thing the
right thing and that doesn't mean it
happens but what do you think the NFL is
going to do if anything before Sunday
I think it's neither the smart thing nor
the right thing to do
simply for this reason I understand how
repellent the accusations are but they
remain accusations and I think what the
Patriots are looking at very strongly
and the league has to consider is there
is no criminal investigation ongoing
it's a civil litigation that's he said
she said so for Roger Goodell and the
NFL PA and all the players in the league
and Bill Belichick himself you have to
weigh what rises to the level of me
taking a player and Quarantine in him
without any cause necessarily except an
accusation and I think that's something
that Bill Belichick cast away as he goes
through this week okay we'll put him on
the practice field because we don't have
any reason to take him off the practice
field because it's not what we would
call yet a substantial allegation that
has involved law enforcement because
every player in there regardless of
Antoniou browser background is looking
to say will you do this to me if someone
comes with an allegation that may or may
not be substantiated and there's no law
enforcement involved so you do you think
you said the Patriots didn't do their
due diligence is it up to the Patriots
to say hey you got any lawsuits coming
up before we we sign you I don't know
what they didn't do their due diligence
but if they didn't ask and they did no
meaningly Brown camp and they went ahead
and signed him anyway that to me yes it
is the onus is on the Patriots tan for
one simple reason what happened in 2013
the Patriots promised it would never
happen again with Aaron Hernandez
they said they were duped they said they
were made to be played the fool by Aaron
Hernandez they you know tore their robes
and expressed so much just apologizing
over and over for what they missed and
they should have because it wasn't that
hard to find especially after the
incidents post-arrest that people began
to relate that he was involved in so yes
the Patriots above all teams to be
asking that question yeah but I think
and I feel like there
relationship it's a business
relationship doesn't Drew Rosenhaus one
is sated with the Patriots have signed
Antonio Brown if they knew that there
was even a whiff of a lawsuit coming his
way and it was based on sexual assault
and or rape I think the football side of
the organization would have I don't know
if the ownership side would have thought
that was a great idea you know I'm just
curious
yet but don't you think I mean if you
think about it you know you know Robert
Kraft is embroiled in something in South
Florida yeah that is ongoing that has
had that he apologized for you know kind
of a blanket apology for the situation
they don't want to have themselves nor
should anyone want to have themselves
affixed to anything that suggests sexual
violence violence towards women treating
women as objects and this is regardless
of how substantial the allegations are
and we continue to look at that as to
whether or not they are substantial in
terms of what the alleged victim is
bringing but it's probably might not
have been a bad idea to wait it out if
you probably if you were the ownership
but on Bill Belichick side if he didn't
think it was substantial and was told
about it I could see him saying we're
just gonna plow ahead with this talking
to Tom Curren Patriots insider NBC
Sports Boston here is a clip from
yesterday's press conference with Bill
Belichick and he's done talking about
Antonio Brown okay anything else on
Miami
it's positioning about the allegations
and I just answered that question how
did that feel you were but what am i but
the fact that he follow up I said no you
actually didn't who did who was the
reporter with a CNN reporter and you
know what look I've had to sit in there
for a lot of press conferences including
with the flake a press conference on the
Saturday before the Super Bowl and take
all the slings and arrows and be the
first guy over the battlements to you
know charged the podium with my
questions and get shot 97 times in the
chest I was happy to let the news guys
handle this yesterday happy you didn't
ask a question with Bello check
yesterday no those guys were on a roll
those guys were rolling I asked the
question the day before of a conference
call about Antonio Brown and in his
disruptiveness and whether or not how
the team reconciled that and that's when
Belichick said well you guys said the
same thing about Randy Moss certainly
this is not shaping up to be the same
type of a situation as Randy Moss within
72 hours of the guy being signed and I
think it was a disingenuous comparison
in the first place I mean I don't know
if our reaction was the same but I do
know the player in this instance Antonia
Brown is less than a week still less
than a week removed from MF and his GM
and threatened him to punched him in the
face
Oakland Randy Moss for all this
ridiculousness didn't have that
immediately in his rear view mirror when
he joined the Patriots yeah I thought it
was unfair to lump Randy Moss in with
Antonio Brown because they I like
Antonio Brown feels like he's unhinged I
mean there's there's I think I had I
would have genuine genuine concerns for
him he's acting erratic and that's you
know Randy Moss wanted out of Oakland
you know but Randy Moss I think all the
counts was a pretty good soldier there
in New England and produced a lot was
great Antonio Browns not even playing
yet and he's bringing in even more drama
here so I like it I think it's unfair to
moss that to lump him in with Antonio
Brown the only person and again you're
right we sit here and we look at this
individual and his behavior and look at
them in the context of this sport but I
think it's unavoidable even for armchair
psychologists which we all are to not
point step back and say I don't know if
this guy's well and when someone's not
well in their life is chaos and it's
another wave hits the hits the beach
sadly you know you think anything could
be in play with that individual and
that's what's honestly scary to me I
mean the only person I can think of
similar this is Terrell Owens and you
know his waiter admissions of how at
wit's end he was and the things that he
contemplated it's it's scary and this is
where the football in the organization
and the limelight intervenes how is this
person going to change because I think
we all know the change doesn't happen
just by going from Oakland to New
England and having a more organized
organization it takes a lot of time and
self work and intervention and
mentorship and I don't think this is a
person who's about to make a sea change
in the way he leads his life if we talk
on Monday what are we talking about with
the Patriots boy man well they were able
to Club the Miami Dolphins 33 to seven
and Antonio Brown had three catches for
81 yards no touchdowns they kept them
out of the end zone but he did speak
briefly after the game talked about just
how happy he was to be in New England
but that was about it
she knows oh no no specific drama during
the game not a lot of hugs not embraces
Tom you told you yeah I think I mean I
guess I don't know I I just I wonder
what the NFL is thinking right now today
as we see callouses it may be I bet the
NFL is absolutely rooting for something
concrete to emerge from law enforcement
that makes their
the job easier because they don't want
as Mike Florio wrote yesterday another
week of as the Antonio turns to dominate
the second consecutive week of their
hundreds you know season as it opens up
yeah so they'd love to find a way but
there's a union there that's gonna sit
and say you can't do that you just can't
do what you're trying to do here Thank
You Tom have a good weekend we
appreciate your time bud thank you
that's Tom Curren Patriots insider NBC
sports Boston for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]